we're learning more about the alleged
activities of a leader of a militia
group that's been detaining migrants
near the us-mexico border 69 year-old
Larry Mitchell Hopkins head of the
United constitutional Patriots is
charged with being a felon in possession
of a firearm now he could face up to 10
years in prison if convicted videos from
the group apparently show militia
members stopping migrants sometimes at
gunpoint near the border in New Mexico
Mireya Villarreal shows us how that is
angered state leaders the united
constitutional Patriots say they are
simply doing their part to enforce u.s.
immigration laws in 60 days they claim
they've captured roughly 5600 migrants
who illegally enter the country to human
rights activists they're a group of
gun-toting vigilantes these are the
kinds of videos you're accustomed to
seeing of you know terrorist groups out
in the deserts of Afghanistan Peter
Simonson executive director of the ACLU
of New Mexico worries migrants are being
subjected to violence and abuse not seen
on video it just makes your heart sink
to see human beings and particularly
children exposed to this kind of a
threat New Mexico's governor and
Attorney General denounced the militia
last week while the Border Patrol warned
them about interference by civilians in
law enforcement matters somebody called
Border Patrol Simonson claims militia
members who often carry badges and dress
in camouflage are breaking laws against
kidnapping and impersonating federal
agents but only one has actually been
arrested 69 year old commander Larry
Hopkins who also uses the alias Johnny
Horton Jr this country was built on
three things
God Hopkins appeared before a federal
judge Monday charged with possessing a
firearm as a felon according to
prosecutors he has three felony
convictions in Michigan and Oregon
including impersonating a peace officer
and that nine guns were seized from his
home back in 2017 Hopkins attorney Kelly
O'Connell says his client is not guilty
of the gun charge which is unrelated to
the malicious activities when he got
arrested
it made it seem like it was something
that was going on down here according to
the accusations it happened up north the
FBI said Hopkins also told them the
militia was training to assassinate
Barack Obama Hillary Clinton and
Democratic donor George Soros on Monday
militia members were dealt another blow
when the owner of the land were they set
up their camp kicked them out they have
to leave by the end of the week for CBS
this morning midday AVL